chez nicolas ker le soleil peine à
pointer le bout de son nez
ces dernières semaines le jura a connu
de nombreuses précipitations une
humidité qui a favorisé l'apparition et
le développement du mildiou un parasite
qui attaquent la vigne ou à bien la
contamination la porte champignons donc
la scène quand le champignon et blanc
sel contamination quelques jours
quelques heures et après on a un
dessèchement de la feuille contre cette
maladie
pas le choix il faut traiter mais là
encore la pluie complique les choses
rendant les sols impraticable et les
produits inefficaces
pourtant si ces villes sont touchées le
tuteur s'estime relativement épargnée
nous à toute personnelle là sur le sur
les vignes on s'en sort relativement
bien on a un petit peu de mesure sur
feuilles
c'était un peu prévisible
par contre on n'a quasiment pas de mine
le sur grappes l'année 2000 21 n'a pas
été tendre avec les viticulteurs
jurassien des gelées en hiver des
averses de grêle le mildiou et les
stocks qui commencent à baisser les
ignorons assiste impuissant à la scène
c'est vrai c'est bien on est la morale
est quand même compliquée c'est
difficile de garder espoir
je pense que les vignerons ils ont mis
une croix sur 2021 c'est clair ça sera
une année absolument catastrophique en
terme de quantité de production la
qualité on sait même pas ce que ça va
donner
s'il espère une météo plus clémente dans
les prochaines semaines les viticulteurs
savent déjà que ces vendanges prévue
pour la mi-septembre seront en demi
teinte et une mise tout sur 2022